Londyn classic is happening again I
wonder how many people are visiting
world championships and then staying for
the London classic only at least one
person Fabiano has to play both events
okay since there's so much talk about
the London I'm gonna play a London I
visited London for the first time back
in February I was flying through back
from back from Asia really cheap flight
from Singapore to London and then a
really cheap flight from London to New
York one of the best ways to get from
Asia to back to the US and then I went
to London two more times over the summer
just to fly through this flight start
crazy cheap and there airport lounge is
really nice it's one of the things
traveling internationally that's to get
lounge access dad man Geum thanks for
the bits I don't know if I need luck
when playing this opening 9 f6 that's
fine 92
yeah this is a line where I learned it I
only discovered it like a beer two ago
that white starts with 92 if the night
we're on f3 and the other night we're on
b1 black would have 94 followed by f5
but ok this position we're gonna have
some we could still transpose in just a
main line it's gonna play Bishop g3
let's start with Knight f3 bit more
flexible did he leave is this grade I'm
so colorblind no it's green I think it
changed though he left for a moment
having some internet issues
so b6 okay so he's signaling that he
wants to play Bishop a6 trade off his
bad Bishop for my good Bishop which I
can't really stop
maybe it's one reason I should have
played Bishop d3 sooner so it's like we
need to to stop Bishop a6 but okay what
to do
I'm thinking playing Bishop d3 here is a
waste of time because he plays Bishop a6
and then I probably would want to take
so I'm looking for a useful move just so
kind of waits debating whether c3 or 95
maybe 95 let's play 95 it's usually not
played so early but it gets reasonable
here
pinkie 5 is on my control if you play as
Bishop a6 I can take then maybe play
Queen e2 with tempo hello Carmer good to
see you
I am making an effort to focus more on
the game than the chats I will take
occasional glances at the chat there
should be sevens another idea so now I
think it's time to play Bishop d3 when
he plays Bishop d7 he's signaling that
he wants to play 94 which is actually a
very reasonable way of playing we could
get some not really symmetrical position
but some very intense position if he
plays 94 there's so much tension which
neither of us necessarily want to trade
but now in this position he's missed his
opportunity because now the knight just
blocks the bishop from helping control
efore also
there's a move that I like to play in
positions like this so I think I'll just
go ahead and play queen bee one simple
idea control the diagonal more control
the e4 square tying the knight down like
he can't play you wouldn't be able to
play 97 on anyway cuz I would take on c6
but Knight is also tied down to the pawn
now I think I want to play f4 I could
castle anytime I just don't see the
reason forecasting right now wait what
what just happened there I thought I I
play die for it but it put the pawn back
but f4 is a legal move know how that
happened it's pretty sure I was hovering
over the square I'm using a mouse with
like at least five different buns people
can see this it's like one of these
gamer Mouse's and sometimes I'll like
accidentally click a button it'll do
something ridiculous but okay F tick I'm
very happy to get a pawn to e5
Knight g4 okay so he wants to attack
this interesting move
attacking III but it seems like my King
side attack should have some potential
worst case scenario I had moves like
this or this I would like to play Bishop
f4 but I'm not actually sure about g5 if
I just castle he takes I play rook up 3
he goes back I play h3 the Knights traps
sometimes yeah the best approach in
positions like this you just have to
think about a normal move imagine they
take whatever they want to take and then
think about how to punish them now I'm
realizing that castling they take III
Rick got three he has Knight f5 I could
win the pawn back but then d4 is loose
what to do I should consider not f1
seriously because h3 is a monster threat
of simply trapping the Knights you might
play Queen g5 but then I have Bishop f4
kini 2 has similar ideas
I feel like I should play kingi too
because my knight wants to go to f3 my
king is okay in the center I think it's
making me to relying on some some
intuition here the buns on the mouse
would navigate yeah I think one bun will
would like go back to a previous page if
you navigate away from the page you
don't forfeit though your time will just
run down if it's your move this is a
second game in a row that I have failed
to Castle as white like the first game I
played King f1 this game I'm playing
king e 2 pretty early but the center is
closed so the center is closed the king
is okay just being in the center hello X
villager good to see you I usually tend
to see the shorter comments like the
people saying hello I hello to the ice
who else said hello hello Amil v DW
that was a long time ago I'm a slow
reader so sometimes a longer comments
are difficult to heat I've been pretty
well lately I haven't streamed that much
like the last time I streamed on me
chess feels like ages ago for those just
joining I was gonna do arena Kings but I
was having technical difficulties with
lag so I feel like the classical arena
is just a classic thing to do just a lot
more chill f6 so he might be sacking I
don't know if it's intentional or
unintentional but after h3 the Knights
trapped I mean he could take here I take
back and then he plays this and it's
actually kind of scary but I'll be up a
piece
another option is to play Bishop h7
first and then h3 but then my bishop
could get trapped so I think the
strategy actually this is I'm realizing
I was gonna say the strategy is to just
win a piece and hold on to it and
weather the storm but the storm is
pretty scary because after I take then
why can't I draw arrows take after efore
Bishop see - he has Bishop a6 his bishop
comes to life I play King e1 maybe I
have ideas of Bishop d1 Bishop e2 he has
ideas of Queen g5 another idea after h3
he takes I take e 4 I have Bishop b5
which could be just better to play h3
I'm gonna win a piece things are gonna
be uncomfortable but hopefully it's only
temporary
then I take e3 I was vaguely considering
this move I don't think it's as powerful
even though my king is on e3 one of the
most active pieces I guess I'll have
Queen g5 check threats actually yeah
this is this is also unpleasant because
Queen g5 is threatening to win a piece
so I can play a bishop taking five Queen
g5 Guinea to Queen take G - that's very
unpleasant
and there's a move here each for this
isn't that what I want to get into
actually no I have to work my way out of
it if I play h4 he wins something on g4
that's a massive Center there's not too
many candidate moves
I mean maybe King e2 but then still
Queen g5 maybe Queen e1
another Canada move I don't think works
but it's possible as Bishop h7 and Queen
g6 preventing Queen G father than he has
regrets
yeah this is this is difficult I mean I
think I should play h4 what else each
for he takes twice on g4 Guinea to e5
we're reaching the point where I would
rather be black here way more fun to
play for black I was probably just
really careless with playing King e2 in
the first place but my opponents logged
off okay let me play h4 before he logs
back in that was strange
I think that's already happened twice
this game so the goal is to weather the
storm I think I have to take I mean I do
have an extra piece I have two bishops
if he takes with night I have Bishop
taking five so we'll take with pawn he
need to only legal move
yeah this is sort of what I was scared
about okay efore is coming and that's
pretty terrifying and my bishop it looks
like it should be a defender but it's
just fuel for the fire so I think the
plan should be to remove my bishop like
Bishop to b5 and and just stay alive
that rhymed okay I mean I'm not getting
made it immediately cuz mmm it's only
his rook doing stuff but his pawns are
are pretty terrifying t3 is coming my
queen is out of play
I love pistachios so the person asking
I'm thinking of a really sad move but it
looks kind of necessary
wanna play it's but what to do queen g1
because my king wants to move back and
my queen wants life and my rook wants
life to I'm not going to resign it's too
early to hiss on my classical rating is
pretty low just relatively I guess
that's the nature of classical chess so
he's being tricky he wants to play queen
g4 and win the bishop
so kini one comes to mind Bishop takes
c6 comes to mind but Bishop takes you
six years Queen Queen g4 right away
Queen h2 comes to mind
this looks really bad though rook Siwon
doesn't work maybe Bishop d6 also a move
kind of like Bishop d6 because it stops
night before in many lines
I feel like if he plays accurately he's
just gonna crush me but I think this is
my best hope have to be active somehow
you would resign here this is still
complex
I mean material wise it's a piece for
three pawns
if I survive and hold on to my piece
things would be great the problem is
things are not looking so good as queens
are on the board he's offline again and
now he's back
I mean this will happen to me
occasionally where I just lose Internet
and it's aggravating yeah this is what I
was really scared of because what do I
do
Queen III this is really bad
there's still a couple options like
couple ways to try and survive but
nothing looks promising
nine of three is one option because this
rook is hanging that doesn't seem to
work at all the problem is okay Queenie
two is very heart's threat to stop so
there's only really two candidates 903
and um Queenie three may be a bishop
take D three but that doesn't really do
anything if Queenie three it was a very
strong move for black which I might just
have to hope he doesn't see but I mean
he's gonna see it cuz it's based on the
way he's playing
and nine of three he takes I can take on
f8 he takes on g2 that's a big problem
there's some funny line I want to UM
okay I want to just calculate this just
for the viewers funny calculation 9 f3
I'm also making the assumption my poems
not watching which is probably not true
he probably is watching but he wouldn't
fall into this anyway 9 f3 King pawn
take f3
Bishop take f8 pawn take G - so he's
threatening me so I would play King D -
let's say he takes her rook in Queens I
take on g4 he takes on a1 and I take on
g7 with meats that would be amazing
and I might just play that because it's
kind of a natural line for black even
though there's so many ways to win that
win in those lines but it's at least one
trick and tricks don't exist in other
lines line of three take take taking D -
problem is he has made into after King D
- I'm so sad but what else to do I'm
looking for tricks after a queen e3d for
Bishop c4 King h8 King 8 7 I've Queen
Jackie for she knew Jade's
yeah at this point I am on the verge of
resigning just looking for final shots
Bishop e6
there should be 6.86 queen g3 I'm not
surviving that
okay made up my mind going for this I
realize on hope in Paris wait I Bishop
to d3 if he takes well Fang things from
the motivation if he takes okay so
Bishop to e3 it's a question of whether
I want to he's offline again never
seemed like someone go offline so many
times yes his wife I just poor
connection
yeah so I mean obviously this is gonna
be played and then it's a question of
whether I want to be hopeful with Bishop
take f8 or play practical with Bishop
take d3 this could be a lost game if he
like if he stays offline and doesn't
return for a while now he's back
I mean I assume it's just connection
issues as what happened to me
occasionally when the weather's bad just
lose lose connection so a problem is
when I take on that fate he takes here I
play King d2 the mate the may than two
is so obvious this is Queen Queen e2
Queen c2 so I mean this is my most
practical try and now at least you twos
defended if he takes I'd have work h2
what to do I hope that someday I can
take on g2 in front of g7
I completely forgot about f2 but I can
take wait
oh I sacked back my piece I'll still
take I have a rook I've two rooks
actually but one rook for the Queen
Wow he doesn't take the Queen good move
Queeny - maybe
I was thinking maybe someday I can
castle but my King has literally moved
to e3 and I'm back to e1 so that's not
happening
no this is just yeah you made a good
decision keeping the Queen on on g4 it's
almost time to resign I'm just curious
how he's gonna finish me off
complicated whether he should take with
the rook or the Queen
Queeny for what a move
wait a minute it's Queenie for Maiden -
Queenie for is made in - was it the only
made in - it was only made in - okay
well I let me defend or let me defend
this way a very suspicious for a player
to be playing this well and then
thinking in this position I mean unless
it's a troll
well that was sad I don't know if what I
want to say yeah that maybe it was just
brilliant play from black like the whole
this whole idea with sacking on e3 at
first it looked on the sound but it was
probably it may have all just been good
I calluses board it's interesting line
because I know like this line is played
by a lot of like strong players but then
the middle gameplay was very very strong
as well everything was strong yeah
look at that graph this will happen
every so often when I play these
classical tournaments what to do